three tails two betrayals and one epic
episode let's break it all down on
Sweetwater secrets
welcome back river babes I'm your
hostess with the mostess Leonide Galera
and this is your sweet letter Secrets
after-show
Riverdale episode 307 chapter 42 the man
in black aka our special three-part
episode now I was going to dress this
Archie this week but considering he
wasn't wearing a shirt for most of this
episode I decided that wasn't a good
idea and since all of our characters
were split up this week I like this
shirt because it has all of our favorite
Riverdale and names on it together and
of course I'm praying for you Betty
thank you so much now fashion secrets
aside let's now focus on this episode
because today I'm bringing you exclusive
answers from KJ Appa about Archie and
Jughead future on the road
plus I'm unleashing my brutal thoughts
in seven seconds in heaven and word
vomiting everywhere and hisses and
kisses but first we need to address this
episode's most shocking twists and turns
in the blue-and-gold
breakdown now episode 307 was broken up
into three stories and we started off
with our most romantic journey with
Jughead and Archie or should I say Cal
this is Beth now the boys have been
robbed while riding the rails and they
stumbled onto a farm looking for help
but before you start to freak out this
wasn't the farm just a farm with two gun
wielding sisters who are mysteriously
all alone shoot him Gracie in exchange
for some help around the farm which
Archie happily agreed to because he
loves any excuse to be shirtless
Laurie offered the boys some food a
place to stay and a whole lot more than
that
now while Archie was doing that Jughead
wandered into the small deserted town of
Athens and noticed a bunch of those
strange symbols a mural devoted to the
gargoyle king and some girls playing GMG
now according to this delightfully
creepy old lady all of the men in this
town are working in a prison that's
creating a drug laced fizzell rocks yes
this same candy that young Hyrum
introduced to the midnight club all
those years ago fizzle rocks
the new Archie stupidly told Laurie his
real name and the fact that he was
hiding from hire and lodge and before he
could ask for a second plate of eggs she
gave me a freaking heart attack and did
this turns out Hiram lodges officially
the man in black he owns the town of
Athens and is blackmailing all the men
to work in his prison and create batches
of fissile rocks because it's okay and
Archie who was being used as bait was
freed by Jughead and then shared his not
so brilliant plan I could kill him but
Jughead smartly convinced his friend to
abandon this ludicrous thought and he
came up with a much better escape plan
instead I'll go see my mom
Veronica story was a lot less
action-packed now in an effort to make
more money for the speakeasy Vee
contacted her old friend Elio and
convinced him to help her throw a
one-night-only casino night the house
always wins right long story short the
trade Veronica shucker the smarmy casino
kingpin had rigged the tables and was
looking to take all the chips for
himself because he knew that veronica
was no longer under her daddy's
protection heard you in England speaking
terms but we all know one thing never
underestimate a lodge
Veronica challenged Elio to a
winner-takes-all game of blackjack and
she defied the odds and came away as the
nice big winner anyone miss lunch wins
turns out Hiram had secretly tipped off
Veronica Chelios nefarious intentions
and suggested that she hire a car dealer
who had stacked the deck in her favor
and unfortunately it looks like Veronica
is starting to warm back up to her
father's icy ways deep deep down maybe
my dad's not so bad Oh
and it seems like sheriff Manette is
dead they don't know for sure because it
was decapitated
the hands were sawed it off and I'm not
cheery note let's venture into the dark
and dangerous halls of the sisters of
quiet mercy for Betty story which was
definitely my favorite because we got to
hear our blonde beauty's internal
thoughts and they were delightfully
vicious tell me what you see Elizabeth a
dead body you idiot I see a toy and
while she played the part of a good
little patient betty was secretly
investigating and discovered that the
sisters are pushing drug laced fizzell
rocks on the girls trapped inside every
patient gets candy for good behavior
but while betty was trying to avoid a
psychedelic trip her obnoxious new
roomie Ethel was always lurking
tattletaling and intentionally pushing
Betty's buttons Betty I don't think Jeff
Hudson to you anymore
Betty decided to sweetly deceive Ethel
to continue her snooping and she
discovered that Hiram Lodge aka the man
in black was secretly meeting with
sister Woodhouse and oh hey there's
Claudius blossom he's alive I don't care
Betty faked a seizure in order to sneak
her way into the infirmary and to get
the secret scoop hidden in her file and
then she dashed down to the door that
Veronica and Tony used to help Cheryl
escape last season but there was just
one supermassive problem
the nuns captured Betty forced fizzle
rocks down her throat and then threw her
into the gargoyle King's chambers by the
end of the episode Betty was no longer
her snarky self
she's now fully under the gargoyle Kings
spell my Savior guide me through the
night well I don't know about you guys
but I really enjoyed this episode and
love that it's setting up the fact that
we're going to be meeting jugheads lon
who is played by actress gina gershon in
the next episode so here's a little
tease straight from KJ Appa about what
we can expect from mama Jones Gina's
coming to be jug mama we call her yeah
I've done a couple scenes with her her
first scenes with me and Jughead she's
great she's epic yeah and she actually
was skate 15 years ago so they saw each
other for the first time again last week
are you excited to meet egghead mama
tell me in the comments below and now
let's keep things moving with seven
seconds in heaven now since our core
four characters were split up this week
there isn't much to report on the
romance front but I would love to
highlight this super sweet voice mail
that juggy left Betty just trying you
again hoping you're okay I love you poor
jug doesn't even know that his girl has
been gargoyle napped by a bunch of drug
pushing nuns but I can't wait to see his
furious reaction when he eventually
learns the truth and while Betty was in
the sisters of quiet gargoyles it was
fun to see her thoughts about those
delusional obsessions about Jughead
things got pretty hot and heavy in the
bunker this psycho [ __ ] oh he
definitely told me about how you
blackmailed him into kissing you as for
Archie well I already showed you that he
was getting hot and heavy with farm girl
Laurie that's on my list of woes yes and
just as I was about to explode with rage
he sweetly surprised me and then pushed
her off and said this there's a girl
back home even though we're not together
anymore I still love her but over with
Veronica I don't know about you but I
was picking up some vibes between her
and Reggie were you getting those as
well tell me in the comments but now
let's sweep beside these romance
whisperings and shout out the cutest in
Caddy's moments and hisses and kisses my
first and biggest hiss once again goes
to Hiram Lodge he is the only character
that we saw in all three of these
stories and on a
I wish I hadn't are you angry about
something I'm frustrated that he's the
man in black because it just seems way
too convenient and I'm tired of him
hogging all the screen time hisses to
farm floozy Laurie first you hop on the
saddle of the first boy you see and then
you smack him over the head with the
world's biggest frying pan honestly girl
what was the point of view huh you just
came here to twist the knife is that it
also side know who else first thought
that Lori and her gun-slinging sister
were related to Evelyn ever and ever
they share the same little buggy eyes I
was hoping you'd say that
hisses - Ellie Oh for trying to pull one
over on Veronica although I'm not really
surprised and - Veronica for starting to
act more and more like her father so
long as you're the last woman standing
and although I always enjoyed these
three-part episodes
I'm sending hisses - the fact that we
haven't seen a lot of our other series
regular characters in a long time Cheryl
has been virtually m.i.a for weeks and
don't even get me started on Josie and
Tony um hello what happened also aren't
these kids supposed to be in school how
many days can you miss it Riverdale high
before you get kicked out oh and hisses
- Ethel's delusional behavior and
obsessions with Jughead we're gonna be a
ship that's all head in your dreams good
luck with that one Ethel you're gonna
need it but I will give a tiny kiss to
this random dead pad line because I
couldn't help but bust Huff laughing but
you really should take the candy it's
super delicious
fully switching over - kisses this first
one is going to Archie's wild hair the
fact that he admitted that he still
loves Monica and - Jughead for keepin it
real with his BFF with this sweetly
intentioned mega burn no offense but
Betty took down a serial killer last
year you can't go for five minutes
without being kidnapped or getting the
crap kicked out of you kisses - how
quickly this episode seemed to move and
- the really amazing shots that showed
just how creepy the gargoyle King's
Chamber were and my biggest kiss of the
episode goes to Betty's internal
thoughts forget jugheads ominous episode
introductions I want more of Betty's
voiceovers because they're snarky and
sensational and they remind me a lot of
young Alice white me
dude can you bite me oh my god and that
wraps it up for this week's after show
for 3:07 now check back to Sweetwater
secrets next week for episode 308
chapter 43 outbreak aka our Riverdale
winter finale because guess what river
babes I have a special surprise coming
your way
brand new interviews with the Riverdale
cast there's going to be so many
delicious and exclusive goodies from the
cast you're gonna think you're high on
fizzle rocks but you're not drugs are
bad until then if you've had a fun time
bouncing around from story to story with
me this week please give this video a
like hit subscribe and then do my
absolute favorite part head on down to
the comments to tell me your thoughts
are you frustrated / disappointed /
annoyed that hiram is the men in black
what do you think jug has mom is gonna
be like is there any hope for Betty now
that she's seen The Gargoyle King and
which of the three tails did you enjoy
the most
ranked them in the comments for me below
and I'll see you next time river babes
kisses to you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]